Hey Thoughty2 Here.
The internet is big, really big, so big that
if you tried to count every webpage you’d
probably run out of numbers, or patience.
The internet is also weird, really weird,
but every once in a while someone finds something
on the internet that just seems a bit too
weird, something so creepy and unexplainable
it makes the hairs on the back of your neck
stand up.
Here’s some of the most bizarre unsolved
mysteries of the internet.
1.
A858 is the name of a mysterious sub reddit.
Since 2011 the unknown owner of the sub reddit
has been posting thousands of long coded text
messages to the sub reddit almost every day.
These strange messages intrigued the Reddit
community so much that a separate sub reddit
was setup called Solving_A858, for the sole
purpose
of attempting to decode the cryptic messages.
The messages appear to written entirely in
hexadecimal, which is a numerical notation
system used in computer programs.
Thousands of people have employed a range
of advanced code breaking techniques in an
attempt to crack the codes but the messages
and the person behind them, still remain a
mystery.
2.
Cicada 3301 is arguably the most mysterious
of all internet mysteries.
It all started on January 5th 2012, when an
anonymous 4chan user posted this peculiar
black and white image on the random board,
it reads:
“Hello.
We are looking for highly intelligent individuals.
To find them, we have devised a test.
There is a message hidden in this image.
Find it, and it will lead you on the road
to finding us.
We look forward to meeting the few that will
make it all the way through.
Good luck.
3301”
Naturally this sent the internet crazy trying
to find the hidden message within image.
Until Joel Eriksson, a 34-year-old computer
analyst from Sweden, found the message.
He knew it was an example of digital steganography.
A way of hiding encoded messages within the
pixels of an image.
Eriksson decoded the hidden message, what
he found was a reference to “Tiberius Claudius
Caesar” and a string of meaningless letters.
Eriksson worked out it was a cipher system
used by Julius Ceasar in private correspondence.
From that he found a new web address which
contained another clue and so the trail continued.
Each clue got increasingly complex and more
difficult to solve.
Nobody is sure if anyone has solved all the
puzzles and got to the end of the rabbit hole.
However a month after the first puzzle was
posted, a new message was posted to the 4chan
message board that read “We have now found
the individuals we sought.
Thus our month-long journey ends.”
Nobody knows who is behind this internet treasure
hunt and what happens to the winners.
Some theorise that Cicada 3301 is a recruitment
method for a global spy organisation such
as MI6 or the CIA, that are seeking code breakers
with brilliant minds.
Others say the Cicada 3301 group is comprised
of military officers, diplomats and world
class academics whom are unhappy with the
current state of the world and are seeking
out only the most intelligent minds from across
the globe to become part of some new world
order.
Yet to this day Cicada 3301 remains one of
the greatest unsolved mysteries of the internet.
What’s even creepier about Cicada 3301 is
that this isn’t just some guy in his parent’s
basement playing a gargantuan practical joke
on the internet.
Because the puzzles led the participants offline
as well, requiring people to find posters
at specified coordinates all over the globe,
including Russia, Japan, France, South Korea,
Poland and the USA.
Which must mean that the Cicada 3301 group
is a large, well-funded, global organisation.
Each year since Cicada 3301 has posted a new
puzzle on the 5th January and a new game begins.
But nobody ever hears from the winners after
they reach the end of the endless maze of
mind bending puzzles, we can only assume that
whatever they are up to, they have been sworn
to secrecy.
3.
Number 3 is the deep web.
The websites you visit every day such as Facebook
and Google are only a very small tip of the
gigantic iceberg that is the internet.
However 80% of the entire internet is not
indexed by any search engine and can only
be accessed by using special applications
such as TOR.
This section of the internet is called the
deep web and it’s mostly stuff you don’t
want to see.
Such as online illicit drug marketplaces,
stolen credit card numbers, human trafficking,
weapons and even hit men for hire as well
as a bunch of other shady stuff.
Nobody knows exactly what’s contained within
the deep web because the majority of it isn’t
listed in any index or search engine, however
it’s said that you can buy literally anything
on the deep web.
And absolutely any illegal and nefarious thing
you can imagine, you can guarantee will be
happening somewhere within the deep web.
4.
If you think the deep web sounds mysterious,
you can go even deeper.
There’s a hidden level of the internet below
the deep web, so deep that nobody has ever
been able to access it, at least that we know
of.
It’s called Mariana’s Web, named after
the deepest ocean trench on Earth.
Mariana’s Web is rumoured to contain a repository
of all of humanity’s best-kept secrets,
including the location of Atlantis.
It is basically the internet version of the
Vatican secret archives.
Some even say that Mariana’s Web is the
home of a super intelligent computer artificial
intelligence that has become sentient and
overlooks and also controls the entire internet
like some omnipotent internet mother nature.
It is said that to access Mariana’s Web
one must use Polymeric Falcighol Derivation
which is a high level maths function that
requires quantum computers to work, and quantum
computers do not yet exist.
However this level of the web is only rumoured
to exist and is most likely just an internet
hoax.
5.
Webdriver Torso is the name of an uncanny
YouTube channel.
Starting in September 2013, almost every single
minute since, 24 hours a day a new 11 second
video has been uploaded to the channel.
However, unlike most YouTube videos, in Webdriver
Torso’s videos there’s not a single cat
to be seen.
Every single video is a series of random blue
and red shapes accompanied by beeping sounds.
Some big companies such as the BBC have taken
an interest in this conundrum and put code
breakers to work to attempt to figure out
what the Webdriver Torso YouTube channel is
all about.
Some people think it’s a modern version
of a “numbers station” which were cryptic
radio signals used during the Cold War to
send messages to spies.
But other think these 11 second video clips
are communications from aliens.
But I’m afraid to say that this YouTube
channel is highly unlikely to be anything
malicious.
In June 2014 it was discovered to be a nothing
more than a test account maintained by Google
themselves, after Engadget emailed Google
about the channel and they replied with this:
"We're never gonna give you uploading that's
slow or loses video quality, and we're never
gonna let you down by playing YouTube in poor
video quality.
That's why we're always running tests like
Webdriver Torso."
However some skeptics still believe this is
just a cover up by Google and that Webdriver
Torso may still have some alternative motive.